okay we gotta sit down for this one
I'm a mom of three kids
please excuse my appearance
I just got home from the gym
I always knew I wanted to be a mom
but I talk a lot on here about my support of the child free people
okay because this is not for everyone
and I was scrolling the little ticky tacky as you do
and I came across this video and oh my god
you have to see this because honestly
watch that
it's a stitch
mostly for a woman
with all due respect
enjoy your selfish self centered self serving life
and enjoy always taking the easy way out and doing everything the easy way
never doing anything difficult or meaningful or rewarding or anything worthwhile
and enjoy dying alone
the hardest things in life will always be the most worthwhile
so if you're that weak
it's probably better that you don't have kids
and by the way
there are a lot better countries
living in Mexico
Mexico's gross and dirty yuck
and it's a good thing you're smoking hot
but you're gonna get old
that too okay
so all the offensive things in one video right
like and just sprinkle a little racism in there too xenophobia
why not
that was one of the most horrific takes from actual parents I've ever seen
and I'm a parent
but wait it gets better
this is the same guy
but I just can't believe that a few like
several years ago
I was on the fence whether I wanted kids or not
or I thought well
they were never gonna want kids
but like
I married you and you want kids
so I guess I'll agree to have kids
but it's gonna be tough
it's a lot of work
whatever literal
same words to me
I just would never have kids because
because then your life's not your own anymore
and you're all about your kids
you're not about you
you can't do what you want when you want
you know kids
it's a it's a big commitment
it's a lot of work
like she said
it's worth it
and like you know
even the the studies in the stats about like
parents with kids are like
they have more problems
they're more prone to divorce
they're more likely to be depressed
and I just thought like well
you know the irony
the data has spoken
we probably shouldn't have kids
I just can't believe now that we have her and she's like
two and a half years old
that I ever would have thought that I wouldn't have wanted a kid because huh
she's amazing
yeah awesome
and she's she's beautiful
and she's and she's
I'm so glad you love your own child
she's she's out there
she has a ton of energy
she's a lot she's super hard to keep up with
she's super hard to like
you know to manage and to stay on top of
she doesn't sleep through the night
she gets in bed with us
she keeps us awake
but like
but she is my favourite thing in the entire world
that's amazing
she's she's kind for you and she's sweet and she's brilliant
and she's got this amazing personality and like
and she's mine and I see like myself in her
in the things that she likes and says and does in her
yeah it's great
being a parent is great
so anyone who has kids can relate to the second part of the video
but it blows my fucking mind
that that guy had all the same arguments
and self thoughts about not having children
and then goes on to shame a woman for having those same thoughts
and coming to a different conclusion for her life and her happiness
how fucking gross
I don't say this a lot
but shame on you shame on you